arthur de grave communicants et auteur
bonsoir arthur de grade merci d'être
avec nous un sondage 1 paru ce week-end
dans le journal du dimanche sondage ifop
seuls 38% des français font confiance au
gouvernement pour gérer cette crise
est ce que cette allocution d' emmanuel
macron ce soir est de nature selon vous
à restaurer la confiance des français
alors c'est difficile de répondre à
cette question puisque on a une opinion
de public aujourd'hui qui n'en est pas
vraiment une puisque tout le monde est
confiné donc on ne sait pas vraiment ce
qui se passe dans la tête des gens et
les gens se parlent moins ou pas par les
questions habituelles donc savoir
comment va réagir l'opinion c'est
difficile à dire donc on verra demain si
je veux pas jouer les marabouts
par contre ce qui est vrai c'est que ce
qu'ils sont de participer largement à
cette perte de confiance dans le
gouvernement dans la gestion de la crise
a été une certaine cacophonie une
communication assez erratiques ou le
président de la république donc le 16
mars et le 16 mars pardon fait un
discours assez grandiloquent avec une
structure en anaphore sur la guerre je
vais vous parler surtout de la structure
et de la forme du discours de ce soir
plutôt que sur le fond je pense que
beaucoup de monde le fera mieux que moi
ce soir et pour autant qu'on avait par
exemple le 16 mars le président de la
république qui nous disait que nous
étions en guerre que quoi qu'il en coûte
les mesures soient prises qu'il fallait
qu'on fasse autre chose de notre vie ou
en prêt qu'on profite de tout cela pour
lire pour se recentrer sur l'important
est le lendemain une liste de travail
qui dit non non par contre vous avez m'a
coupé va falloir retourner au boulot là
effectivement on a des mots qui engage
un discours qui se veut plus sobre une
forme de discours d'atterrissage
c'est à dire qu'on a moins d'effets de
manche on a un ton moins grandiloquent
moins lyrique quelque chose de plus
factuel et un horizon temporel assez
assez restreint le diable par la queue
on est encore dans ce discours on donne
un horizon de sortie de crise sanitaire
en tout cas de sortie de confinement pas
de sortie de crise sanitaire
on connaît une forme d'incertitude sur
ce plan là et sur la presse sur ce qui
viendra après on reste assez vague pour
autant j'ai quand même noter quelques
mots qui font presque mine de conversion
dans la bouche des manuels mais quand
j'ai entendu le mode relocalisation
j'ai entendu une bonne planification et
ça c'est intéressant alors la question
pour moi à ce stade c'est de voir
comment concilier ce propos
présidentiels ce soir donc qui se veut
qui siffle un peu je veux dire par là
qu'on fait on a eu des éditorialistes
france notamment eric le boucher dans
les échos hier me semble-t-il qu'ils
aient il faut sortir du confinement
maintenant pour sauver l'économie
un certain nombre d'économistes plutôt
proche du pouvoir porter des positions
assez similaire là apparemment ce n'est
pas l'option de déconfinement c'est pas
tout de suite ça va prendre du temps on
va apprendre à vivre avec
donc on a priori un contre-pied qui est
pris que ce point de vue là la question
c'est comment réaccorder ce discours
avec les déclarations qu'il était temps
été faites notamment je pense du côté de
bruno le maire hier et aujourd'hui dans
la foulée notamment des déclarations du
président du medef qui appelait on
s'acquitte évoqué l'après en disant il
va falloir faire des efforts il va
falloir revenir sur les congés payés il
va falloir revenir sur sur le temps de
travail dont qui annonce c'est quand
même un après qui n'était pas forcément
mon nouveau concret comme certains
veulent appeler de leurs voeux
le fameux monde après qu'on trouve dans
certaines tribunes assez inspiré qui se
veulent très optimiste qu'on trouve à
droite à gauche sur internet
donc ça ne semblait pas annoncer ce
genre de choses comment réconcilier des
déclarations de ce type là avec le
discours présidentiel de ce soir ce sont
des mots forts ce sont des mots qui
engage une forme d'atterrissage quand
même on attend une communication
élyséenne qui était un peu on peut de ce
fait rien de grave
effectivement il a commencé son discours
emmanuel macron la france à l'évidence
n'était pas assez préparés à la crise
c'était important peut-être d'utiliser
une parole de vérité effectivement la
france n'était pas prête à cette crise
difficile où effectivement à ce stade
étant donnée la perte de confiance que
vous évoquiez tout à l'heure de
continuer à expliquer tout allait bien
que non non il n'y ait pas eu je veux
dire ça fait partie aussi des éléments
des ratés de la communication
gouvernementale de ces dernières
semaines d'avoir eu différentes voix au
sein du gouvernement qu'ils sont allés
contre l'évidence
je vais pas refaire la liste on ennuie
un certain nombre au cours des semaines
écoulées
là effectivement ça participe très
largement de cette perte de confiance
est de cette défiance même vis-à-vis du
gouvernement donc effectivement c'est un
en termes de captatio benevolentiae pour
prendre un vieux terme de rhétorique
on ne peut pas faire autrement dans ce
cas là effectivement que reconnaître
reconnaître une part d'erreur ce que je
constate aussi donc c'est il ya quelque
chose qui m'a frappé c'est que la
métaphore de la guerre à la métaphore du
nous sommes en guerre et passe en demi
teinte on entend quand même première
ligne 2e ligne à des cas quelques termes
champ lexical guerrier mais globalement
on s'en éloigne un petit peu on célèbre
même eu l'esprit français
un rigolo qu'il appelait pourtant
lui-même les gaulois réfractaires
sénéchal mans il ya encore quelques mois
en disant que justement les français
continuent à avoir des débats continuer
à faire de la politique continue à
critiquer et en s'en félicitant la ce
qui est une rupture par rapport à cette
ligne aussi cette première ligne qui
venait du 16 mars qui était cette nuit
de la guerre et donc l'union sacrée donc
quiconque quiconque critique rem en
actions du gouvernement aujourd'hui ne
serait pas ne s'engagerait pas dans la
lutte contre le virus
là on a effectivement une petite
inflexion de ce côté là mais encore une
fois je suis très curieux de voir la
suite concrète qui sera donné à ces
déclarations et comment le reste de la
communication gouvernementale va
s'accorder autour de cette de
l'intervention de ce soir il faut ce
sont des mots qui engage et on demande à
voir
merci beaucoup arthur de grave
communicants et auteurs d'avoir été avec
nous mêmes